with respect to the security the g7
remains strongly united in support for
Ukraine will continue to provide
economic support and technical
assistance that Ukraine needs as it
moves ahead on critical reforms to
transform its economy and strengthen its
democracy as we've seen again in recent
days Russian forces continue to operate
in eastern Ukraine violating Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
this is now the second year in a row
that the g7 has met without Russia
another example of brushes isolation and
every member of the g7 continues to
maintain sanctions on Russia for its
aggression against Ukraine now it's
important to recognize the Russian
economy has been seriously weakened the
ruble and foreign investment are down
inflation is up the russian central bank
has lost more than 150 billion dollars
in reserves russian banks and firms are
virtually locked out of the
international markets martian energy
companies are struggling to import the
services and technologies they need for
complex energy projects Russian defense
firms have been cut off from key
technologies Russia is in deep recession
so Russia's actions in Ukraine are
hurting Russia and hurting the Russian
people